[Music]
here are some BuzzFeed lists I saw
recently check this one out not-so-good
22 people firefighters regret rescuing
could have gotten off the phone now I'll
save that douchebag look at this 14
former serial killers who now work at
Old Navy oh boy I know that guy
look at this eight cats who like
watching their owners do it creep 12
photos of Jose Canseco with cartoons
sunglasses on what is that all about
that should be in the Smithsonian
I know 14 women without eyes or ears who
support Donald Trump 9 sandwich artists
you won't be famous till after they're
dead look at this one 9 yoga instructors
who are just making [ __ ] up as they go
what about this one
29 high-fives that ended in marriage oh
yeah look at this one which character
from the racist 1915 film Birth of a
Nation are you
that's just bummed everybody yeah but
you're in there somewhere you know you
are 47 public restroom toilet seats who
can't believe you think you had a day
don't even get them started
47 oh yeah yeah when you got a toilet
seat complaining yeah yeah 14 American
celebrities who were considered food in
Malaysia
[Laughter]
and finally 19 pregnant women who don't
know their child will be a total death
[Applause]
you